[Music]
in worst wrong turn ever news submitted
by Bart's PR song what is it one of my
favorite ones is the [ __ ] problems I
love bad [ __ ] but the stripper song
is this true persona I like I love it
hmm it's 2 Chainz is it 2 Chainz a bunch
people on - 2 Chainz ASAP I love bad
[ __ ] that's my [ __ ] problem oh
that one yeah suppose for you a British
family was jailed after crossing into
the u.s. from the Canadian border I
heard about this I know we move past
this but now I'm curious with European
both borders um what's my PR it's a
couple of go to gyms I only listen to
metal in my gym I only listen to either
like Metallica or heavy metal or ariana
grande I love I love I got it oh I like
that one I like all of them but I don't
know thank you next but I like those I'm
not gonna sing it for you do it do it no
let's watch it we do it um it's like the
it's like her album cover song it's like
um I don't know the words make
everything taste like it so when you
come through like this week no you wanna
thing the fan of days to a hub and get
it get it get it
I know the song but I don't know the
lyrics either I don't know you think
really good do you done left to that
song or squat to that song or bench that
song ahh both but sometimes bench I need
a little bit more Metallica you know cuz
you lived I keep thinking that you have
chalk dust on your shoulders
no it's tie-dye yeah that's cool you
know you got the chocolate straight from
the gym yeah I should do like a shirt
that's like that yeah that'd be steal
this design yeah okay
so this story here this British family
but they were they're claiming that they
have been heavily mistreated by the US
government
oh no so they were saying that
they were on vacation in Canada plannin
ass redcoats so actor yeah yeah so then
so they were saying that they were on
vacation
and they were also so it's Eileen who's
24 with her husband David who's 30 and
their three-month-old baby come on
Eileen very young why are you going on a
road trip in Canada with a three month
year old from the UK so something's
fishy right so then venturous so they're
also saying so they were also with
another couple and like with twin kids
creepy old all those seven people and so
they claimed that they were on this road
and they had to swerve quickly to avoid
an animal which took him to onto a small
road and then yeah right after that
happened that's when all of these a
Border Patrol people came in and they
they arrested him and said you entered
the US illegally without being inspected
that's illegal you're going to jail and
so they ended up taking them to a jail
and they were just detailing how
horrible horrible of an experience they
had how like her husband was taken to a
freezing cell and she how she had to be
in a separate cell with the baby but it
was so cold and they they they just got
those metallic mylar emergency blanket
oh yeah it's like foil foil and so
that's all we had and they were forced
to sleep on the floor and because she
was trying to like keep the baby warm on
her chest but then like he was like
flying off and like Audis the baby as a
pillow yeah that makes more sense than a
blanket huh so small yeah well she's
trying to keep the baby warm so then I'm
create a lot of heat you'd be surprised
keep the big one on the back of my head
mm-hmm so then they're not claiming that
the baby has blotchy skin and a possible
infection from
oh and then at one point that the baby
was left completely naked for several
hours in the cold jail when his clothing
and blankets were taken to be washed so
how long were they detained for um so
they're saying so like initially they
went to it like a first jail and then
they told them that they were gonna be
picked up by family in the US and so
they were family in the u.s. that's how
they were reporting this and then they
said that you can't just get picked up
yes I know legally right so then they
said and they were just like we just
want to go home this is horrible like we
don't want to be here it was by accident
we didn't even mean it
and then after that they went to an
airport oh because and they said no
you're not you're not being picked up
we're getting you to an airport and then
that's when they thought they were gonna
be going home but instead they went from
Seattle to Pennsylvania where is one of
three detention centers for immigrants
and so that's where they were taken and
then that's where they were just having
like a horrible did they split up the
baby no so like she was claiming that if
because she was like how can I keep my
baby in this freezing cold cell and then
they're like well we can take the baby
away from a home yeah according to her
so it's just this is a couple they look
like some Geordie Shore kind of the hell
was this picture taken in the 80s
yeah that's it being there from the
Geordie Shore damn Oh or they're from
Essex yes that's like oh that's like New
Jersey of Britain yeah it's like Jersey
Shore
but I was so to me it doesn't seem like
like how do you accidentally cross the
border and if your animal turned you
around wouldn't you go back on the road
you came yeah like I think you have to
go out of your ways across the border
because I've never seen an entry point
to the u.s. from coming from Canada I
mean I've only been a few places in
Canada coming crossing the border but
I've never seen an entry point that was
just like I've never heard of an entry
point that's just like I smell rose
there's a lot we're trying to trap you
like oh I wouldn't imagine maybe I'm
wrong but like I would assume that
they're not trying to trap you in like
oh you went down the wrong road you're
going to jail like I think they're
they're probably signs that are like you
are now crossing the US border right I
mean maybe if you're in like that
country farmland then they might not
have those borders like that but I'd
imagine road trip is this don't you have
a map when you're a little bit they were
saying that they were just trying to get
back to their hotel like they didn't
know that they were in a you have GPS on
and now we've been traumatized so this
happened on October 3rd and to my
knowledge they're still detained I think
oh so wait did they check the hotel
records like that they didn't check out
of the hotel or were they still supposed
to be I know now they're saying they're
reporting that this couple intentionally
like went into the u.s. so their their
vehicle was their vehicle was captured
on video quote slowly and deliberately
driving through a daze you have like
American flags going like oh yeah to
enter the US through a ditch that
through a ditch why didn't they just
enter normally so even so it turns out
they're felons they had previously
applied to enter the US but they had
been denied so they wanted to be illegal
immigrants I think yeah or they just
wanted to travel for fun so people from
the UK need visas yeah I knew a guy from
England he got deported because I didn't
need a visa or we didn't need or work
travel visa though
well it's different from there to here
every every country is different that's
why I like sometimes people get so
excited about traveling to other
countries I'm like your border police
are scary in every country yeah and you
sometimes need to apply for a specific
visa just to go for a few days people
don't always know that like there's some
things you can't take in certain
countries yes some countries like the
more friendlier we are with these
countries like if you go to Japan right
I think the you could be there for 30
days or something or 60 without a visa
yeah you could you could go in do
whatever you want you just snap your
passport says British citizens do not
need a visa to visit the US but they do
need to apply online for an electronic
authorization so you can keep track of
how long you've been there yeah if
you're from the UK you even if you don't
apply and like have a paperwork for a
visa you still enter on a visa like it's
a tourist visa yeah well you don't
really need much for it but if you break
the contract to that visa then that's
when you [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah it seems like
that's what that's their intention since
they did all this like you would say I'm
like I was just going on a road trip in
South Korea I didn't mean to enter North
Korea you know like they're gonna you
can't just break borders like that and
then expect nothing to happen and then
also the u.s. is denying their claims of
being mistreated yeah that's true it's
all what they're saying yeah I don't
know I've never been there have you seen
orange and black yeah no that's my
that's my show recent show where they
show like the life not that it's
obviously it's fiction you just started
it well the last season they give some
story lines on women who get finished
with their sentence and then they're in
a like ice detention Hall because they
weren't citizens of the United States
but they were serving their time and
then they're in a detention hall yeah
after their imprisonment yeah to make
their case for staying in the u.s. so
they have that whole storyline which I
didn't even know that was the thing that
could happen mm-hmm they thought they
were going home and then yeah
that's crazy I did look [ __ ] on the show
so I imagine it's a glamorized version
of what it actually is yeah but this but
initially when this was being reported
everyone was just like British family
jailed after mistakenly crossing
Canadian border into u.s. like poor them
they just they accidentally Tamils just
fishy just it just seemed crazy and and
but I mean y'all are good detectives cuz
you called it out
no Mike yeah yeah I don't want to like
go based off of what they were saying
but it just seemed kind of odd that they
went in a lot like a country road or
whatever and all of a sudden they're
surrounded yeah mmhmm yeah cuz most
entry points are pretty official yeah
there's people there there's like a big
little sign yeah coz to me I would have
thought smugglers
yeah human smugglers or drug smugglers
are fugitives yeah yeah usually you know
you don't think like good people are
taking back roads in in the freezing
cold yeah they're talking about it being
freezing cold so what about the other
family they're detained as well or they
were traveling with them as far as I
know they were detained and how bad of a
you know what kind of a record that they
had that they couldn't come into the
States that's my real question yeah or
maybe they were here and they overstayed
their visa that could be it too and I
know
British people who overstay their visas
and they get in trouble yeah and he
can't come back or they work or outers
well one of the cases I know is a guy
who has a girlfriend who's from the US
and he was just like yeah I'll come to
the u.s. for like two months and then I
leave for a week and then I come back
I'm like it wasn't my business but I'm I
probably shouldn't do that like that's
that's illegal
you're like finding a loophole in the
system when you should stay tourist visa
from the UK you can say for six months
and then that's like you can't just
leave the country for one day and come
back and that's kind of what he tried to
do assuming that he could just get a new
tourist visa but you can't you can't do
that that that will like [ __ ] up your
life because you can never come
I mean depending on how good like your
legal team is you can never come back in
the country Ryan just got his green card
and they asked him he's Canadian my
fiancee and they asked him in the
meeting they said what happened in 2005
when you entered the US border and he
was like oh no I was like 14 yeah I
don't remember what happened I can't
remember what happened but something was
flagged in the border police system so
where they bring it up so it's like
anything that goes wrong in that process
they will bring up one time I went from
Canada to the US for like one day I was
staying in Canada for a few months or
yeah for a few months but I was like
still obeying my visa tourist visa and
the border police questioned me so much
the Canadian border creaks police
questioned me so much just saying like I
mean that's how it should be marry him
for like citizenship
oh it's suspicious if an American
traveler leaves for one day and goes
back right away it's like what are you
somebody trying to do
maybe I didn't turn off the stove mm-hmm
and they're like your house you live
here are you trying to live here
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]